Kim is in Chicago hi Kim welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show how are you better than
I deserve what's up well I've got some
questions here my husband and I are
looking to retire and end of June and
I'm trying to figure out how to handle
some different money resources that
we're going to have told her well I'm 62
he'll be 65 so cool and we've got the
insurance worked out so we're all set
that way mystic yeah wish it was more
but in my 401k I probably get about
200,000 he's got a pension that will be
about 75% of what he was earning hmm
what is how does he make now he's at 110
and I'm in a hundred ok so you have a
$75,000 or 70 $80,000 any of your income
okay correct all right and you have
200,000 and a 401 K and what else and
then what we've my thinking was you know
you won't have as much debt and
retirement because things will be paid
off but what we've got we have a condo
in Florida
that's rental investment property and we
have a mortgage on that but we still net
probably about 20,000 a year on that and
so we'll keep that and then we have a
house that we bought in Florida that
we're currently renting but that's the
one we're going to move into so that one
I have a mortgage on the house in
Illinois is paid for so much is the
mortgage on the house in Florida the
balance mm-hmm about 220 what about the
condo the Kanda's about a hundred ninety
okay so but the kind of probably worth
four
and the house is worth about three and a
quarter what's the house in Illinois
worth the house in Illinois should sell
for about three and a quarter and so my
question is what to do with the proceeds
out of the house in Illinois do I say
also house in Florida that you're gonna
live in as I'd sell the condo okay cuz
pardon me I'd sell the condo hmm
you would why would you do that because
I don't want any debt going into
retirement and you can't afford to pay
it off well I mean it could sell it if
you had to pay it off but well so you
can sell it if you ever tried to sell
condo in Florida when the economy turns
down you can't give the damn things away
yeah kind of good right now I know right
now it is don't wind and stupidest
stress tested it'll catch you so I mean
you're sitting there with a bunch of
debt acting like you don't that's a
$200,000 debt and you don't have but
$200,000 to your name after you pay off
your house so I want your home paid for
for sure that you're living in going
into retirement and all you gots 200
grand to your name did I miss something
man you come on anyone pension income
yeah I tell you but when he dies you
don't have that income well yeah the way
it's set up I still would
okay I'll reduce motion okay yeah and
then the condo in Florida though makes
more money than assuming that's wanted
heaven well that's pretty much a rented
out it's right on the ocean that's its
vacation rental okay you do whatever you
want to I don't care sure it's your life
you can do what you want to I'm not
going into retirement with a dad if you
can figure out a way to pay off this
condo I'd keep it if you can't figure
out where to pay it off I wouldn't keep
it you don't perceive the risk that I
perceive here I think you're heading
towards a wall